le centre de calgary c'est le monde des
banquiers des pétrolières et des
commerçants comme spider maxwell un
conservateur depuis toujours qui votera
cette fois pour le libéral que parce que
dit il le politicien a véritablement sa
circonscription à coeur ses nuits
il explique à des étudiants en médecine
comment il a réussi l'impossible passé
de hockeyeur à politiciens
quadriplégique après qu'une balle de
fusil lui a traversé le coup le nouveau
défi de qu'un pur rafler cette
circonscription du centre de calgary
depuis longtemps d'allégeance plutôt
conservatrice il est confiant selon lui
tous du rock et à ses 7 ans en politique
provinciale en passant par son handicap
tout la préparer à représenter
calgary-centre le message libéral ajoute
il séduira les électeurs de calgary mais
ces commerçants se montrent sceptiques
aucune sympathie pour justin trudeau
mais une conviction qui saura lui tenir
tête
le candidat est accessible soutien tels
ils nous écoutent et puis ajoute
celui-ci l'image de calgary doit changer
à ottawa et le meilleur pour y arriver
elle voit les conservateurs en danger et
combien les appuyer à nouveau rien et
donc gagner pour cadrer un mais qu'une
lutte serrée se fasse ici entre libéral
et conservateur
c'est déjà le signe d'un grand
changement
mascara radio canada à calgary